foreign
[Music]
briefing for Tuesday December 6th I'm
Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
over the past few days you might have
noticed your social media blowing up
with people posting lists of the music
they've listened to most this year
that's right it's Spotify wrapped season
that time at the end of the year when
the audio streaming platform playfully
shares with users some of the
information it's gathered on them but
why is it that we find this information
gathering so fun and other data
collection so intrusive
with me now to talk about that is our
personal Tech columnist Nicole Nguyen hi
Nicole thanks for being here hi Zoe So
for people who aren't familiar with
Spotify wrapped can you just briefly
describe for us what it is Spotify
wrapped is a year-end analysis that the
company provides to its users and it
tells you things like how many minutes
you streamed your top artists and it
becomes something of a social media
event because it's kind of like a
personality quiz but for your musical
year
so what did you learn about yourself
from these stats this year Spotify told
me that I spent exactly 12 000 35
minutes streaming this year just over
200 hours and for the first time Spotify
is also assigning musical personalities
so I learned that my musical mood shifts
from intense uplifting soothing in the
morning to acceptance escapism cathartic
in the afternoon and then I'm also an
early adopter or someone who is quote
always seeking the next hot thing which
sounds about right
you know often data collection has this
bad reputation so why does Spotify
advertise to its users at the end of the
year that it is collecting this data on
them I think it's a really smart move by
Spotify for them it's a marketing
campaign to get people talking about
Spotify and sharing their stats on
social media but for me it's a reminder
of how much data these companies are
collecting about Behavior or activity
and the potentially interesting insights
they have about us that we aren't even
aware of ourselves you know like for
example Peloton probably knows which day
you're the laziest or Netflix knows
which kinds of thumbnails you're most
likely to click on and the user
researchers and data scientists at these
companies are probably running these
insights but they're not sharing those
with their users even though they're
collecting this kind of data all the
time and Spotify wrapped is unique in
that they are not only collecting you
know data collections typically oh
one-way exchange between the user and
the company they're also giving some of
that data back to its users is Spotify
the only company then that's doing that
reversal that's giving it back
Apple music and YouTube music also have
their own version of this although it's
not as comprehensive as spotify's and
Strava also has a your year in sport for
the athletes that are signed up for that
platform
what if you don't want to be a part of
this I mean is there a way to opt out if
you don't want Spotify or your music
provider collecting your listening
information if you sign up for Spotify
then you agree to its terms and Spotify
will collect this listening history
regardless but you can prevent it from
showing up in things like wrapped or in
personalized playlists like discover
weekly or daily mix by turning on a
private listening session so if you have
a kid you know who loves listening to
baby shark over and over again you can
prevent that from showing up in your top
tracks unwrapped okay so for all the
parents on social media complaining that
their wrapped was ruined by their
children there is a way out you
mentioned that you agree to Spotify as
terms of service when you sign up for it
and imagine they're not just collecting
your listening information right yeah
they're also collecting data like your
location which they can infer from your
IP address which is pretty common for
services and that's for the purposes of
providing you more personalized
playlists based on where you are or also
for advertising which is relevant to the
free tier of Spotify
we wrote this column saying that this is
one of the few occasions where you don't
mind that your data was gathered I mean
why not I love seeing my wrapped every
year because it tells me something about
my own behavior that I didn't already
know and I think that's
one of the beautiful potentials of
Technology you know we usually think of
data collection as neutral to evil which
you know sometimes it is when our data
is shared without our consent or more of
it is collected than we had hoped but
Spotify wrapped is kind of a data
collection bright spot it's an example
of Joyful date of collection I love
seeing what band I loved most this year
because it says something I think about
where I was at musically and emotionally
for the past 365 days
so do you think other companies that are
collecting our data should be sharing
more of it with us I think so our data
is so often monetized or used to improve
these products and if these companies
want their consumers to be more
comfortable with their data being
collected than they should show them the
kinds of useful insights that users can
glean from their own data all right
that's our personal Tech columnist
Nicole Nguyen Nicole thanks so much for
joining us thanks for having me and
that's it for today's Tech news briefing
if you want more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
[Music]